good morning John
[Music]
now
what's the best thing about big country
I'm meeting advanced bug in the dance
dodging there are no winners in the
makeup challenge everyone loses this
year's that God is bigger than ever
VidCon is great she's amazing I love so
many different things about it
[Music]
VidCon 2014 the fifth annual VidCon five
years of VidCon and it's coming up in
like two hundred and thirty days but
tickets are on sale now we got us a
tumbler now it's VidCon BLR tumblr.com
VidCon blur and we're on Twitter and
Facebook if you have questions to ask we
got answers it's crazy how big it's
gotten like seeing on that footage as I
was editing that video but I feel like
it's still such a special cool time for
online communities to come together in
the real world and I'm just really proud
of it and it's great and so thanks to
everybody who supports it and everyone
who can't come I'm sorry that it exists
in the real world and so is constrained
by space-time John the idea that
nerdfighteria is going to sponsor a
professional football team I just want
to say that I think this is this amazing
idea I don't know it just feels pretty
cool I've gone on a lot approved has
finished its first like story arc so if
you don't want to watch in sequence but
you want to binge a little bit now's a
good time to binge there's a playlist
link in the description Jon's punishment
I came up with a good punishment for
John sort of a mix of various
suggestions the idea is Henry I think um
has some unique ideas about cuisine John
for your punishment Henry makes the
dinner he decides what goes into what
and what gets cooked how as long as
you're not gonna poison yourself and
then yeah you have to eat it basically
I'm letting your child punish you Oh
also we are in the middle of the 12 days
of pizza myths last year we had a bunch
of limited edition Pizza John designs
different colors different designs this
year instead of doing that we have
decided to put this on a bunch of
different things there's a hoodie
there's keychains there's a little pail
pane coffee mugs guitar picks frisbees
also a fleece blanket with the pizza
John face on it pencils journals mouse
pad socks like with the stitching Pizza
John face I'm super excited about that
cuz I like weird sock all these things
are available for pre-order from now
until the 15th and then on the 15th they
will never be available again also if
you're confused about the new YouTube
comments I made two videos on Hanks
channel on about how to add your Google+
page to your YouTube account which you
due to about how I feel about the new
common system some good some bad and by
total and complete coincidence a promise
subbable also just launched comments so
we've got our own common system going on
over there finally I had cursed me
somewhat belatedly that the pumpkin
carving contest wasn't particularly fair
because the people who posted early got
a lot more votes from the people who
posted later we're putting everything
into a separate poll vote for your
favorite now things do all the carvers
and all the voters John I'll see you on
Wednesday Tuesday all the people named
Carver out there like oh oh I expect to
see you Carver's in the comments